hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
heute geburtstag aber ich mache trotzdem
video hier vielleicht wisst habe ich
höhenangst zwar nicht die sonne mega
krasser als ich war auch schon auf so
einer krassen brücke aber sagen wir es
so ich habe respekt vor der höhe also
wenn ich irgendwie auf hohen gebäuden
bin dann komm ich muss jetzt schon
stottern
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht das wird
nicht eher zu meinem kanal passen als
eine kombination von leuten die
irgendwie von hochhäusern nicht springen
aber darauf herum laufen und skateboard
tricks machen und purzelbäume da auf der
kante ich würde einfach mal sagen ich
klick auf play und wir schauen uns das
ganze mal an
okay ich bin raus der ist über de ich
bin raus okay okay
bist du lebensmüde er springt hier und
machten purzelbaum auf ihn hört auf den
fakt dass gerade mega ab weil ich mache
als total ängstlich oder guckt euch das
an ok das geht noch wenig weil er da
noch
der boy
ich war schon auf dem world trade center
obendrauf
das ist somit eines der höchsten gebäude
der welt und da hatte ich sogar schon
angst aus dem fenster zu schauen und
jetzt guck ich mir so was hier an alter
er fährt mit einem hammer portugals
herrscht weder bist du komplett
bescheuert in einem kopf wie er machte
alter schwede
gerade der rutscht ab und fällt runter
hier dreht er sich mit seinem hobart und
jetzt macht er hier einen purzelbaum
jetzt dachte ich wow per rutscht ab aber
nein er setzt sich hier nur hin und
treibt seine hände jetzt ok go ja du
bist nur du stehst wittler auf eine mail
bist du nein nein
er wird dort an der scheiße was habt ihr
alle mit euren verfügten was okay
[Musik]
okay das macht den hitlergruß hier das
hier ist nicht mehr nur lebensmittel
sondern das ist lebensmüde hoch zwei
weil da sind zwei menschen
leute ohne spaß ich spiele gerade nichts
mehr ich weiß nicht wie man auf eine
idee kommt sowas zu machen indem wollen
die leute irgendwas beweisen wenn paar
sekunden später
vielleicht mir weil ich mich das nicht
trauen würde
die sitzen auf einem egal ob warte warte
warte warte warte er macht doch nicht er
hat seinen er hat seinen er hat doch
nicht wirklich
[Musik]
wow
als ich vor zwei jahren bei dem video
days in berlin war habe ich dieses foto
hierauf instagram hochgeladen und habe
ich mich einfach auf das höchste
stockwerk eines gebäudes wohnt mein
manager
er hat mir davon abgeraten habe ich
einfach hingesetzt hat meine beine
baumeln lassen und das war auch so im
siebten stock dann also quasi im achten
stock und das dass das muss ich sagen
das war schon krank aber das hier das
ist einfach nur krank wie stehen auf
gegen nimmt ihnen norm rundturm erklärte
doch nicht wirklich erwartet wahrte
das ist ein fucking riesiges hochhaus
und erklärt an der fassade hoch was ist
mit den menschen los wenn die das machen
was ist mit dir denn je was mit dir denn
falsch
er hängt lässt sich einfach runter
hängender es fährt skateboard das doch
nicht wahr
nein mach es nicht das ist doch so ein
komischer boden da muss was macht ok
ok
warum steht eigentlich die ganzen herzen
was fällt ihm einen da einen purzelbaum
runter zu machen und dann einfach
abzubremsen sich dann wieder festhalten
da eine rolle also bist du denn total
behindert
real tormann ist doch nicht mehr ganz
korrekt im kopf drin wenn man so einen
schwachsinn macht alter schwede ist der
irre bisher hast du den platz eins also
das ist nichts gutes du bist einfach am
leben müdesten von allen hier erfährt
bmx aber ich glaube er ist halt auch
professioneller bmx-fahrer das heißt
dass er sich natürlich trotzdem weh tun
kann aber auch
jetzt drauf gehen können die ja ok
er sprintet da lange macht parcours das
sieht man da unten rechts sogar noch
eine ablage das heißt es ist noch ganz
okay da vor gott
sachen nicht er macht jetzt auch wieder
ein salto hier
ein sal
o
und auch ein rückwärts
foto
und er springt komplett darüber ok alles
klar halt hat schon mal pro er läuft
über diese teile wo also endlich krieg
schon höhenangst wenn ich das überhaupt
anschauen er sitzt auf irgend so ein
stern der lässt sich einfach aus einem
zu baumeln er springt über irgendeinen
gerüst drüber ich verstehe immer noch
nicht wieso man das überhaupt alles
macht er hängt immer noch an seinem
komischen haus da ich weiß auch nicht
was es für ihn bringen soll er
unterdessen gab
aufnahmen das finde ich das sieht nicht
so heftig aus also das ist
wahrscheinlich viel viel höher als die
anderen sachen aber ich finde es sieht
klasse aus wenn dies wirklich so was
alter schwede er hängt an seinem arm
mag
also ich muss mal
ein paar sekunden später
seid ihr komplett lebensmüde okay dass
man jetzt eine ganz kurze anmerkung von
mir und ich meine soll ja jeder machen
was er will also wenn jemand lebens müde
ist und so ein risiko eingehen will mit
seinem leben zu spielen dann ist es ja
vollkommen in ordnung dann kann er das
ja machen aber er sieht dabei halt also
ich denke mir wenn leute das machen dann
die sind jedoch irgendwie auch glücklich
dass zu machen oder also ich meine warum
sonst sollte man das machen und die
können bin ich sagen dass das hier
glücklich ist ich meine der typ sieht so
aus erst musste er das machen guckt euch
das an der ist total zittrig der hat
auch gar keinen bock dran lächelt da
irgendwie so ungewollt in die kamera und
ich stehe auf irgend einem stern und
warum machst du das wenn du da keinen
spaß dran heißt also wie kann man auch
spaß an so was habe ich verstehe das
nicht er hängt ja wenigstens noch über
dem wasser das georgi da hängt er nicht
mehr über wasser
das war es hier wird dem heutigen video
meine damen und herren
diese kombination geht zwar noch zwölf
minuten aber ich arbeite geburtstag und
wollte gleich noch feiern wenn euch das
ganze video gefallen hat und ihr dass
eventuell noch mal sehen wollte dass ich
das noch weitermache und mir weiter
anschaue dann las man vettel liegt da
hier findet jetzt hier einen smiley
eingeblendet darauf könnt ihr meinen
kanal abonnieren es kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr da oben
findet ihr auch meinen shop eingeblendet
und hier unten irgendein anderes video
verlinkt und da dass wir jetzt vorbei
ist könnt ihr das hier euch mal
anschauen